donc taslima nasreen vous êtes né en
1962 au bangladesh donc l'ancien
pakistan oriental vous avez fait des
études de médecine êtes devenu
gynécologue
mais parallèlement vous êtes l'auteur de
romans et d'essai dans lesquelles vous
prenez fermement position contre l'islam
et où vous dénoncez la condition des
femmes musulmanes
on y viendra en 1993 vous publiez la
honte qu'il même titre que kery james
mais malheureusement pas pour dire la
même chose ou vous raconter les
persécutions d'une famille hindoue au
bangladesh
ce qui provoque l'indignation des
musulmans puis vous accorder une
interview un joint de calcutta qui
s'appelle states man où vous évoquez la
charia la loi islamique et vous demander
un meilleur traitement pour les femmes
mal vous en prend deux cent mille
islamistes défilent en demandant votre
pendaison vous êtes obligé de vous
réfugier dans la clandestinité et dans
l'exil
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes comme salman
rushdie victime d'une fatwa
il ya une prime vous abattre est ce que
vous savez de combien et le montant de
la prime
cette plainte est gris ont été testés
500 $ ce qui n'est pas beaucoup d'argent
ceci dit pour que les femmes du
bangladesh et de pauvres c'est énorme et
il m'aurait volontiers pour les sommes
pareils mais je ne vis pas dans mon pays
aujourd'hui je vis en exil j'ai été
obligé de quitter et c'est un peu comme
ma fille j'ai essayé d'y retourner mais
ça n'a pas été possible disait tout à
l'heure
juste avant votre arrivée vous dites
comme kery james il n'y a aucune
différence entre l'islam et le
fondamentalisme islamique
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de différence
entre l'islam et l'intégrisme
parce que l'intégrisme islamique je suis
l'islam véritable slam ne parle pas de
la paix à la dans le coran dit que les
femmes sont inférieures aux hommes
il n'y a pas d'égalité dans le mariage
temps d'un divorce la garde des enfants
alors l'héritage dit que les incroyants
d'actu avec les intégristes ont demandé
que je serait pendu ou tuer parce que
dans le coran il est dit que je devrais
être tué parce que j'ai re ni l'islam
je suis devenu athée je ne crois pas la
religion
vous avez des gens qui peuvent être
modérés qui ne croient pas un sujet
massacre qui peuvent être mis entre eux
mais ce n'est pas le coran qui le coran
dit ne soyez pas la nuit par exemple des
jeux il faut des chrétiens parce que
sinon vous allez en enfer et donc ceux
qui ne croient pas ils iront en enfer
il n'y a pas de paix kery james que vous
entendez ça vous réagissez comme ans ce
qui est certain et ce qui est confirmé
c'est que
dieu dit non au corps un honorer ce qui
signifie dit donnez vos preuves
si vous êtes véridique et je suis sûr
que si on interroge mademoiselle et
qu'on lui demande de citer un adversaire
avec les références où il est serait dit
ce qu'elle prétend qu'il est dit elle
serait incapable de nous répondre le
prophète mohamed arale un sauna tôt à
sanam est venu avec une religion de paix
moi je sais d'où je viens et je sais
quelles ont été les conséquences de
l'enseignement musulmans sur mon
comportement aujourd'hui et tout à
l'heure vous avez mentionné le fait que
je ne serai pas la main aux femmes ou
que je n'utilisais pas un certain genre
d'instruments dont tout cela il n'y a
pas de contradiction avec les fondements
de la république
donc j'arrive à vivre en france en
respectant les gens sont sans troubler
l'ordre public et j'arrive à vevo
complètement ma ma religion est ma
religion m'a appris par exemple à
patienter face aux injustices
lorsqu'il m'est parvenue l'histoire de
cet homme noir à médine qui est un des
grands exemples pour nous les musulmans
qui se trouvait dans un marché et qu'un
homme s'est mis à l'insulter et l'homme
lui a dit oh c'est bien toi que j'ai
ensuite élu il a répondu c'est bien toi
que j'ignore
j'ai su alors que ça c'est un
comportement qui est beaucoup plus
difficile à adopter pour la facilité de
l'agressivité je voudrais dire elle a
dit quelque chose qui me paraît très
important c'est que la religion devrait
être une affaire de morale personnelle
et moi je me pose toujours la question
dont on parle au nom de la religion
qu'est ce qui se passerait si la
personne qui me parle avait d'un seul
coup le pouvoir
toute la question est là la démocratie
n'est garanti qu par la séparation des
pouvoirs tant que vous avez l'église
séparer du pouvoir politique à ce moment
là ça devient une affaire d'éthique
personnelle il ya aucun problème mais
quand les affaires de l'état et celle
d'une religion sont mélangés ça donne la
possibilité à des gens d'imposer leur
point de vue aux autres gens c'est une
situation que nous avons connue très
longtemps en europe qui n'existe pas en
france simplement depuis le début du
siècle la séparation de l'église et de
l'état c'est le début du 20e siècle en
france ça devrait être une garantie de
démocratie sur toute la planète
à
partir du moment où le pouvoir religieux
et le pouvoir politique son ensemble il
n'est pas possible de garantir la
liberté de choix des individus et en
particulier la liberté de choix des
femmes qui sont effectivement comme le
dit est slim à toutes les religions
opprime les femmes toutes sans exception
sans aucune exception
pas l'ombre d'une exception moi ce que
je sais ce que j'ai appris ce qui est
confirmé ce que le prophète alliance en
date ouazana me l'a dit rio loco roco
mené à aller ce qui signifie le meilleur
d'entre vous c'est celui qui est le
meilleur avec sa femme son enseignement
que j'ai reçu c'est ça les bénéfices ne
s'adresse pas aux femmes savaient déjà
dire le meilleur d'entre vous si celui
qui se comporte mieux avec sa femme ça
veut dire que c'est un discours qui ne
s'adresse qu'aux sommes justement il
devrait dire le meilleur ou la meilleure
d'entre vous est celui ou celle qui se
conduit le mieux avec son conjoint ou sa
conjointe dans sa saisie pour évaluer
donc voulu vitesse lima la seule
solution c'est la sécularisation des
états islamiques séparation de l'église
et de l'état comme ça a été le cas
évidemment en france au début du 20e
siècle
vous dites que le conflit en fait n'est
pas entre l'occident et l'islam
il est entre le fondamentalisme et la
laïcité
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de conflit
entre l'occident et l'islam
les gens pensent qu'il y à une guerre
mais la guerre c'est entre la laïcité et
l'intégrisme un peu ce qui est
irrationnelle et ce qui est rationnel
entre les gens qui veulent la liberté ce
qui ne leur est pas une éducation
séculaire est absolument importante
surtout dans les pays parce qu'on lit
gyan est enseigné à toutes les écoles ce
sont des écoles religieuses des
agresseurs et c'est une adresse 1 ce
sont des écoles religieuses et ce sont
vraiment des usines un fondamentaliste
et nous devons absolument les arrêter
l'éducation religieuse devrait interdire
et la politique fondée sur la religion
devrait être interdite il fait la
laïcité la sécularisation
parce que ce moment là les esprits des
gens seraient sécurisés et c'est la
seule solution ce n'est pas en tuant les
musulmans que vous allez régler les
problèmes taslima est quelqu'un qui a
été très héroïque de d'être une femme
dans un pays qui est extraordinairement
intégristes et qui l'a menacée et les
charia sont évidemment quelque chose
contre lesquelles nous tous
nous luttons et l'intégrisme dans toutes
les religions est une chose à bannir et
c'est vrai que quand on dit intégrisme
ça veut dire que c'est un mouvement
extrémiste à l'intérieur de la religion
est là où je ne suis pas d'accord avec
madame nasreen c'est que en même temps
on ne peut pas mettre toutes les
religions dans le même bain la religion
c'est quelque chose pour essayer de
rendre les gens meilleurs toutes les
religions pourquoi est ce que les
prophètes ou suit les prophètes
pourquoi est ce que jésus christ a été
un c'est quand même des messages d'amour
alors évidemment il ya eu des
intégristes catholiques c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu l'inquisition et qu'on l'a brûlée
et des femmes comme des sorcières il ya
eu des intégrismes dans toutes les
religions mais ce sont des excès ce sont
des choses qui arrivent
malencontreusement et l'intégrisme
convoi l'intégrisme musulman
c'est une chose assez récente car quand
c'est aussi une question de lecture de
ces versets quand on essaie de lire le
coran de manière un peu naïve le corps
ans à huit siècles le prophète c'est à
huit siècles c'est c'est bien après
jésus-christ bien sûr eh bien on y lit a
quand même beaucoup de poésie il ya
beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de messages de
miséricorde et bien entendu on peut
également lire ce coran de de deux
manières dévié et faire dire aux choses
ce qu'on veut laisser passer quand même
une lecture qui est ainsi la bible aussi
on peut la lire comme avec avec en
accablant
oui je sais que beaucoup de gens parlent
de l'interprétation qu'on m'attaque
différemment les textes mais comment
est-ce que vous pouvez pas traiter de
façon positive
ce que le coran dit quand il dit que les
femmes sont inférieures et que les
hommes sont supérieurs
comment est ce que vous pouvez
interprété ça autrement que si la femme
n'obéit pas à son mari il a le droit de
l'abattre je vois pas d'interprétation
positive la tête tout tout ce dont tout
ce dont elle parle ce n'est pas ce que
ce que moi ce que moi j'ai appris de
l'islam et le prophète avait un solde
fans et se trouve dans ce rallye ça nous
a appris que la distinction se fait par
le d'obérer c'est à dire par la piété
c'est à dire que celui qui fait le plus
preuve de piété c'est celui là qui est
meilleur que notre qu'il soit il faut
que ce soit une femme où que ce soit
dans sa tombe
je crois qu'une religion ne devient
sympathique et ne devient clémente que
quand elle est contrôlée par d'autres
gens que quand elle n'a pas le pouvoir
total de totalitaire de contrôler la vie
des gens toutes les religions deviennent
très sympathique la religion catholique
qui brûlait les gens le tribunal
tribunal de l'inquisition c'était
quelque chose de terrifiant est devenu
quelque chose de tout à fait tolérant
dans la france d'aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils peuvent pas faire autrement donc
je crois que tout ça est une question de
rapport de force et d'équilibré des
pouvoirs donc servir à autre chose moi
je crois que monsieur que je ne connais
pas que je ne connaissais pas avant soit
franchement il ne fait pas l'effet des
trains intégré suis dangereux je le vois
vraiment elle a vraiment une bonne et
une bonne vibration quand même on en
parle
oui ça arrive et papa de la même pas de
la même école faisait même boutique mais
ça arrive et et voilà c'est une question
de rapport de force comme d'habitude
c'est une question d'équilibré de
répartition du pouvoir s'il avait l'air
de rien tu aussi
merci beaucoup d'être venu avec nous ce
soir et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu